Ahora vamos a resolver ecuaciones un poquito
más complicadas, ok,
tenemos aquí una ecuación por ejemplo 3
por "x" más 5 igual a 17,
¿quedaron bonitos los colores no?
el chiste es que esta ecuación no es como
las que estábamos viendo, ok.
Si aquí tuviéramos nada más "x" más 5
igual a 17, lo podríamos resolver muy fácil,
nada más tendríamos que restar 5 de los
dos lados del igual, o por ejemplo, si nada mas tuviéramos "3x" y no estuviera por aquí este 5,
entonces también, nada más tendríamos
que dividir entre 3 de los dos lados del igual
y ¡listo! ya habríamos resuelto nuestra ecuación es lo que hemos estado haciendo en los últimos videos.
Pero aquí tenemos a los dos,
tenemos "3x" más 5 igual a 17,
aquí como que nos estorba
este más 5, ¿no?
entonces ya no podemos resolver esta ecuación
como en el video pasado.
Bueno, pero de todas formas la podemos resolver.
Ahora, para hacerlo lo que yo propongo es
que veamos primero cual es el fondo de esta
ecuación, qué es lo que nos está diciendo,
verlo de una forma tangible y resolverlo no precisamente con peras y manzanas, pero más o menos
y ya después ver lo que significa todo lo que hacemos en el mundo de las ecuaciones
y del álgebra y entonces resolver esta ecuación
con puras operaciones.
Y bueno, espero todo tenga sentido una vez
que hayamos terminado, pero bueno,
empecemos con la forma tangible de resolver esta ecuación. Ok, tenemos aquí, "3x" más 5 igual a 17,
¿qué es lo que eso significa en el fondo?
Pues aquí este "3x" lo que significa es que
estamos sumando "x" tres veces, ok, entonces tenemos
aquí, "x" más "x" más "x" más, ajá,
esto de aquí es tal cual "3x" y después tenemos
aquí un más 5, o sea que estamos sumando
5 unidades, ajá, y bueno, de hecho vamos
a dibujar cada una de esas unidades,
aquí tenemos,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5...
Entonces tenemos "3x"...
"3x" más 5...
más 5 que es esto de aquí y tenemos que
eso es igual a 17...
y sí, vamos a poner las 17 cositas, ok,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14 ,15 ,16, 17, ok.
Esta ecuación es exactamente lo mismo que esta ecuación de aquí.
Ahora, estas dos cosas son exactamente iguales, ok.
Entonces si nosotros quisiéramos tachar un objeto por acá, tendríamos que tachar otro objeto por acá,
para que estas dos cosas siguieran siendo iguales, ok, eso es lo que pasa con las ecuaciones,
todo lo que le hagamos a un lado del igual, se lo tenemos que hacer al otro lado del igual.
Ahora, ¿qué cosa podemos hacer a este lado del igual? para que nos quede tal cual como
lo que nosotros ya conocemos y sabemos
manejar perfectamente
o sea, para que nos quede algo así como "3x" igual a algún otro número por acá y entonces
ya nada más tengamos que dividir entre 3 de los dos lados del igual y obtengamos "x" muy fácilmente.
¡Ah! pues lo que nos estorba son estos objetos ¿no?
entonces a nosotros nos gustaría llegar
y tachar estos objetos y que desaparecieran
y entonces nada más nos quedaran estas
tres "x", pero todo lo que le hagamos a este
lado, se lo tenemos que hacer a este lado,
entonces aquí si tachamos 5 objetos,
tenemos que tachar por acá otros 5 objetos, ok...
1, 2, 3, 4, 5 y listo, esto de aquí es igual
a esto de acá, ok, porque tachamos la misma
cantidad de objetos de los dos lados.
Bueno y eso algebraicamente, ¿qué significa?
Pues, si quitamos 5 objetos de este lado
podríamos pensar que estamos restando 5, ok, pero también quitamos otros 5 objetos de este lado,
entonces por aquí también restamos 5 y si hacemos estas operaciones, pues nos queda "3x",
3 por "x" y aquí nos queda más 5 menos 5 y
eso es igual a 0, o sea, "3x" más 0,
que lo puedo poner o puedo no ponerlo, da lo mismo,
ok, entonces nos deshicimos como queríamos
de este 5 y ahora sí, vamos a obtener una
ecuación de esas que ya sabemos resolver,
pero pues esto no nos sorprende tanto ¿no?
o sea, porque lo vimos aquí, teníamos tres
"x" más 5 unidades, 5 objetos, tachamos los objetos y pues lo que nos quedó es simplemente "3x"...
aquí está "3x" ok, entonces "3x" es igual...
y aquí podemos hacer dos cosas, uno, es hacerlo
aritméticamente, tenemos 17 menos 5,
eso es igual a 12 o podemos regresarnos a la forma
visual de nuestra ecuación y ver que aquí
teníamos 17 objetos y tachamos 5 objetos
y podemos contar cuantos objetos nos quedan.
Entonces nos quedan, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10, 11, 12...
y ahora sí, esta es una ecuación que sabemos
perfectamente cómo resolver, tenemos aquí
"x" su coeficiente 3, entonces nosotros sabemos
que nada más tenemos que dividir entre 3,
de los dos lados del igual, porque este 3
se va a cancelar con este 3, ahora visualmente,
¿qué es lo que estamos haciendo?
Pues estamos dividiendo estas dos cosas
en tres pedazos iguales, ok, pero bueno, aquí
teníamos estos objetos que ya habíamos tachado,
entonces yo digo que los tenemos que borrar
para que no nos estorben y ahora sí, queremos
dividir estas cosas en tres pedazos iguales.
Ok, vamos a partir aquí y aquí y entonces
tenemos nuestros tres pedazos iguales, y aquí queremos partir estos doce objetos en
tres pedazos iguales. Ok, entonces partimos
aquí y aquí y ya tenemos
nuestras tres partes iguales y entonces nosotros
sabemos que cada uno de estos pedazos va a
ser igual a estos pedazos, ok.
Tenemos que "x" es igual a 1, 2, 3, 4...
y algebraicamente por acá, tenemos que multiplicar
por 3 y luego dividir por 3, es como no hacer nada,
entonces nos queda "x" igual a...
y 12 entre 3 pues es igual a 4, ok,
"x" es igual a 4 y pues obviamente obtuvimos lo mismo que con la ecuación desarrollada de esta forma,
ok, "x" es igual a 4.
Bueno, ahora vamos a hacer otro ejercicio,
no vamos a escribir todos los números como
objetos de esta forma, pero espero que notes
que estamos aplicando el mismo tipo de procesos.
Bueno, vamos a hacer una ecuación ligeramente más complicada, tenemos aquí "7x" menos 2 igual a...
¿y sabes qué vamos a hacer?
que las cuentas no quedan perfectas,
para que haya fracciones y toda la cosa.
Entonces vamos a poner por aquí, -10.
Ok, está ligeramente más complicado, pero
nada del otro mundo, ya podemos resolver este
tipo de ecuaciones y bueno,
¿qué es lo primero que queremos hacer?
Pues queremos hacer que este lado de la ecuación,
quede de una forma más simple,
o sea, como las de los videos pasados
donde tenemos nada más "7x",
o sea, nos queremos deshacer de este -2.
Y una muy buena forma de hacerlo es simplemente
sumar un 2, ok, porque entonces -2 más 2
es igual a 0, pero recordemos que estamos
en una ecuación y si queremos que se siga
preservando la igualdad, o sea, si queremos
seguir diciendo que esto es igual a esta otra cosa, entonces tenemos que sumar por aquí otro 2.
Ok, entonces hagamos las cuentas, tenemos aquí "7x"...
"7x" más -2 más 2, pero eso es simplemente
0, o sea que aquí podría poner más 0 o
podría no ponerlo, da exactamente lo mismo,
y eso es igual a, pues aquí tenemos, -10
más 2 y esto, pues ahora va a parecer un
repaso de suma de números negativos, pero a ver, ¿cuánto es -10 más 2?
Entonces vamos a poner la recta numérica
¿no?
Tenemos por aquí 0... mjmmm... tenemos por
aquí 1, 2 y bueno, digamos que tenemos por
acá el -10, entonces por aquí está -9,
-8, -7 y bueno, por aquí está el resto de
los números ¿no? nada más que no los
podemos poner todos, ok.
Entonces tenemos -10, empezamos en -10...
y después le sumamos 2, para sumar,
lo que hacemos es saltar a la derecha dos espacios
y entonces nos quedamos por aquí ,
o sea -8, ok, es muy importante recordar esto de
la suma de un número negativo con un número
positivo porque no vaya a ser que nos equivoquemos
y digamos, ¡ah! 10 más 2 es 12... ¡ah!
pero tenemos aquí -10 entonces tienen que ser -12...
¡No! este -10 está por acá y si le sumamos
2 tenemos que saltar al otro lado de la recta
numérica y entonces nos queda -8.
Ok, entonces tenemos que "7x" es igual a -8
y ahora sí, ya tenemos una ecuación como
las que sabemos resolver muy bien.
Ok, entonces lo único que tenemos que hacer
es dividir entre 7 de los dos lados del igual,
para que este signo del igual siga teniendo sentido y entonces cualquier cosa por 7 entre 7
nos queda simplemente esa cualquier cosa
y esto es igual a -8/7, que podemos sacar
el - de la fracción y nos queda así...
-8/7 ó podemos escribirlo como una fracción
mixta y entonces nos queda que "x" es igual a menos...
y el 7 cabe una vez dentro del 8 y nos sobra 1,
entonces esto es 1 entero y 1/7.
¡Y listo! Ya terminamos.